[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Dennis you made history in the 1996 NBA
Finals when you pull down 11 offensive
rebounds in two games in the same series
how many total rebounds both offensive
and defensive do you have in that series
against Seattle 80-78 be 87 see 88 d 91
remember 30 years ago that went six six
games right 6 games you guys beat
Seattle four tests I'll say uh 87 I'm
gonna say be 87 Minnesota the correct
answer is C 88 okay so Dennis got it
wrong so now this is the other half of
the equation this is the most important
part Ray if you bet with Dennis then
you're personally responsible for a
piece of human history being destroyed
ya know but if you faded tennis who's
going home a lucky camper me yes okay
oh no what did you do Trey I
I don't want to do this tray I don't
want it I don't wanna do it
[Applause]
carefully will destroy me
[Applause]
[Music]
oh that's terrible I was even tough for
me how was that emotional life in
Caesars Palace
this is PRS game day game show